tell me how have you seen her
the woman in the arena
her face is scarred
her body bruised
when she rises up
like the sun in the
moon who counts
[Music]
the crowd has heard surrounded
they don't like what she's about and the
worst they drive
hateful bombs
she dusts them off
no one else can sing her songs
[Music]
who can
with their words
[Music]
in
[Music]
and she says
if your hands ain't dirty
if your heart is searching
[Music]
you can't hurt me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
your heart
[Music]
you can't hurt me
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
what did you want to be
when you grew up
when i was four i wanted to be a dragon
fly breathe fire inspire
you can probably guess what people told
me
by the age of 12 the biggest dream i
could imagine for myself
was to sing jingles on the radio
and maybe one day i could be a backup
singer
i mean let's face it i would never be
the kind of musician who would really
make it
red carpets grammys stadium tours i'm
queer
i'm catholic
i'm an indie artist i sing bilingual
music
i had swallowed the message the world
loves to tell little girls be grateful
for what you have
don't take up space
be small
and i was really good at that
until
my last day in the studio
to record the title track
for my latest album
now for those of you who understand the
meaning of la camanda
you'll know i had to get this song right
but y'all i tried i had 30 different
versions trying every different melody
and inflection i could think of and it
just wasn't there and the truth was it
was all too
pretty
and la quemando was not pretty
she was stunning
she wasn't a mere she was demanding
a raging fire in your chest ancient and
sassy and true
but there behind the mic
i was anything but
i was lost
time wasting in the studio and no ideas
left
i looked at my producer and i said
screw it
roll the track
i'm just gonna scream
and see what happens
and there it was
a sound unlike any i had ever made that
would land me on the red carpet as a
2020 latin grammy nominee the third u.s
born latina to ever be nominated in the
pop rock category and the first
queer texan
and as i stood in awe of the sound
that had unleashed from inside of me i
realized i have found the voice
deserving of the title la camanda
the woman in command
the woman who calls the shots she boss
the boss
woman
see
when i named my album la kemanda
i accidentally
gave myself permission to be her
as it turns out
little girls can breathe fire
[Applause]
[Music]
okay
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
a
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you